fun Group Welcome to Detention Spencer Bethany fridge Martha
You're all here for a reason. You know what it is
You should be thinking about who you are and who you want to be
Fortunately you'll have plenty of time to figure that out while you're cleaning out the basement
that sucks
You Spencer who this's  jumanji a game for those who seek to find a way to leave their world for hi
We load  avatar names so you pick a character, and then you're that person again stronger boot
I don't think it matters that much should be Do we play it?
What's going on
What happens your hand
Holly shit
ah
wear the rest of me. Oh my God bridge
Damn fridge. Who are you me spencer? Who is she?
Martha
Think we got sucked into the game we've all become the avatars of each other so that means I'm stephanie oh
Bevan Bethany
I'm an overweight middle-aged man
Welcome to Jumanji
everybody run
Why I am  go so slow
I have to warn you think I'm a very strong puncher
Don't cry don't cry cry. It's gonna be okay alright alright
I can help her